yes we've got to have some of the most
watched races in the whole country and
one National Group is trying to get
Democrats to the polls with one
questionable strategy eight news now
investigator Vanessa Murphy has more
some nevadans are receiving this mailer
about the November 8th election stating
who you vote for is private but whether
you vote is a matter of public record we
will be reviewing public records after
the election to determine whether or not
you joined your neighbors in voting
that's actually a tactic that's been
used by groups to try to actually
encourage people to vote Danley is an
associate professor of political science
at UNLV he points to research showing
this strategy Works a 2008 Yale study
concluded social pressure increases
voter turnout as we know that a lot of
people don't vote especially in midterm
elections they don't think the vote
counts that it matters so groups are
continually trying to get people to turn
out and vote and one way is to use
social pressure
could it work the opposite though of
rubbing a voter the wrong way yeah so
this particular flyer it does seem a
little aggressive and that's similar to
what the Nevada Secretary of State's
office is saying when we reached out
about the mailer a spokesperson wrote in
an email while it seems aggressive it
does not appear to meet the threshold
for voter intimidation so who's behind
it America votes a left-leaning
Washington dc-based political action
committee there is a local division
which in this 2022 overview released
Tuesday States it's working to re-elect
Catherine Cortez masto for Senate Steve
sisilak for governor and the Slate of
progressive candidates up and down the
ballot I think voter turnout is
especially an important for Democrats in
Nevada this year because you know
Biden's approval ratings are low so
Republicans have a lot of motivation to
turn out to the polls not so much for
the case for Democrats that's kind of a
concern for Democrat campaigns just
trying to get the turnout try to get
their supporters to turn out and vote we
reached out to America votes and a
spokesperson wrote in part there is a
lot at stake in this election and we
encourage everyone to make their voice
heard we requested an interview and
additional information for example how
many of these ballots were sent to
nevadans we haven't received a response
yet Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now